[Music]
there is no day
to see how much to help you in
california in which don harris will have
big spanish the referent dominique in the
garden get happy the life for a dream
keep big spanish i am the
integral boasts of the children in going from es
better than immersing yourself with the prat you hear
they don't have now I speak very perfect Spanish
in this regard it would be
dyn
this river
[Music]
which one do you want to do which then with a
Madrid studio they mess with manny
pérez chiquito easy easy
as they say yes no
[Music]
ok
is out of the water
for our intelligent citizens I
did not understand
this back then and not if you hamas like the ine
[Laughter]
I am intelligent thank you grace as
every time another shore knows that it
is for that for  this for kristen art
in the item in a brief way insight
I ask her about one thing and she tells me 50
thousand I don't understand
gray but this is green window sale
office kitchen camera
we are more the same than different 20
minutes
[Music]
88 min 88 songs my sincere
888 888 pesos but I don't know what he's
saying he can give me he's saying
that he's a stripper who dances to this
song and it's the most famous song he
's doing that's the universe he
understands  I understand what
10 look is giving me heat we did not make it
more difficult than times the feeling
I would never have called in the head of
all pod after none the mission
pieces bomb in wine and I can't
wait where he goes I think when he
talks to me  Estela forgets that I don't speak
that language she
doesn't know what's going on
[Music]
he doesn't know that he can't do it
because women are smarter
than men so he knows that you're
finished for
a minute
[Music]
explain to me
[Laughter]
[Music]